[Music]
you are not going to get too far on that
thing anymore are you I will be taking
these back to the jewelry store you
stole them from but you keep these if
you'd like kind of idiot still things I
cannot run bullets that guys should be
the criminal clothes to work for what
not to do it reflects what's going on
guys the biggest question that you guys
had after the flash finale is how iris
West was able to hits avatar with a
bullet so I'm going to explain the
circumstances in the reason why the show
did that because as you can see
present-day Barry who's slower thence
Avatar Barry is able to outrun in easy
at point-blank range so there's the how
part and then there's the why part the
why was the most important but we'll
talk through the head-scratcher
practical application first there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so the flash show is still so much
fun but sometimes you see twists like
this and you kind of sense what they're
going for but then you go back and you
rewatch an episode this is from episode
2 where he's just running in circles
dismantling the bike while he's also
dodging all these bullets here you can
keep these I'm going to take these
diamonds back to the bank if that flash
on an average day and Savitt are
supposed to be a time remnant of Barry
from 8 years in the future who
presumably has gotten better with his
powers by that time trying to defeats
avatar you get better and better and
better trying to defeat this big villain
then there are a couple things that you
can point to that we're just slowing
Savitt are down so really you have to
distinguish Savitt are from the time
remnant Barry he's really like full
Salvatore when he's in the costume he's
much faster because the suit helps him
harness the Speed Force it has all this
cool tech that creates this frictionless
bond between him and the environment so
he doesn't create the same amount of
drag that Barry does even though
technically the Speed Force is the
explainer around that in the back half
of the show there was this big thing
where Tracy brain was like hey wait a
minute you run really fast how do you
get around the buildup of heat how are
you able to deal with friction so they
talked about the hazmat fire suit that
Barry wears well we have a couple ways
but then they find out about sabotage
costume which is a way more advanced
version of that
you get two episodes 20 21 plus and you
see Sabbat are out of the costume you
see him phasing he has lightening that
looks very similar to berries so you're
like okay clearly he's not quite as fast
as he is when he's inside the suit so
even if sabot R is at full power when
he's outside of the costume here he's
standing up from a standstill so he's
not getting the same launch as if he
were starting a race like Barry and
Wally when they're racing here so
already he's at a slight disadvantage
but you also have to assume that Barry
just cracked the hell out of his back
when he fazed him out of the sabotage
suit and into it himself so this is one
of those examples where a villain is
wounded but they don't really show that
to you like he's lying here he's almost
passed out he's on the edge of death but
he still stands up he finds a little bit
of strength left in him to stick it to
Barry one more time so he's finally
going to try and do the thing that we
wondered if he was going to do all
season long like directly kill Barry
himself is basically erasing both of
them so already he's not thinking very
clearly because he kills Barry he kills
himself he erases himself from the
timeline but he's also really distracted
nobody's paying attention to Iris he
doesn't know what's happening behind him
so he's been wounded he's not thinking
clearly and somebody behind him has a
gun which also you know still pretty
quick even under normal circumstances
the flash would have to focus in order
to catch or dodge a bullet so I think
there's this misconception about Flash's
abilities so yes he's connected to the
Speed Force but it's not like a Wonder
Woman thing where he's always at 100%
strength he moves at normal speed until
he wills himself to move at SuperSpeed
so when he's pursuing something unless
he's focusing on it it's not really in
his peripheral vision he's still subject
to a lot of the same things that other
people are if you tried to shoot someone
and they were looking at you they could
try to dodge but if they weren't paying
attention it'd be a lot easier to get
them in the back most of the confusion
here is just because you don't see that
sabotage been wounded I feel like if you
saw him like hardly being able to walk
like oh my God my back is broken it
would my make a lot more sense that he
wouldn't be nearly as fast as if he were
at full power that's really the how the
why which is actually a more important
reason from a writing standpoint like
the whole reason why they wanted him to
end this way an iris to be the one to
kill
Candice Patton said in that video iris
had to be the one to kill him is because
somatically what's been going on all
season long so you have flashpoint
sabotage basically like the culmination
of Barry's bad choices and his fears I
can't deal with the pain so I'm just
going to be the most selfish person
possible become a god and use everybody
to achieve that end darkest timeline
Barry worst thing ever the red herring
was Iris's death that was the thing that
was hanging over their heads almost all
season long no matter what they did she
was going to die they had to try and
change that so she's like this damsel in
distress somebody saved me there's
nothing I can do so in a very basic
level it's just them saying she's not a
princess that needs to be rescued by
other people she's not like this special
flower that needs to be protected all
the time I can take care of myself to a
certain degree obviously if a super
villain is coming after me then I'm
going to need a little bit of help from
Team flash what I think they could have
done is a slightly better job of showing
iris fixing problems herself and show
you know like I'm not a damsel in
distress to be rescued because when they
found out about her death she sort of
rolled with it like oh my god what are
we gonna do she almost shut down a
little bit because you look at episodes
like this from the beginning of the
season where she walks up to this gun
like she's daring this guy to shoot her
in a really fearless way but none to
that energy bleeded into Team Flash's
plan to try and save her like most of
her plans were just part of Barry's
plans like we got a train Wally to save
iris we got a look at this Lego diorama
for hours on end trying to figure out a
way to stop savat are
we got to create the Speed Force bazooka
and it all turned out to be red herrings
none of this stuff was going to work
they just had to use a little phase
changing device gets avatar to forget
about iris in the brief moment of his
rage against Barry in his plans being
foiled in order for her to slip a bullet
between his shoulder blades so it was a
bit of a mess I think they could have
solved a lot of those problems by just
showing iris having a little more agency
in the back half of the season with the
save iris West plan like they just kept
trying to change future things but none
of it really addressed the idea of what
iris was going to be doing about trying
to save herself there were a few moments
that they slipped into that final
episode right before the finale where
Joe's talking to her about handling a
gun like I taught you how to shoot you
know how to use this right she's like oh
yeah I know how to use this they
addressed that a couple times during the
season but not nearly in the way that
they set up the phase changing device
that was a major plot point way back in
the first half of the season
maybe revisiting that earth to badass
detective version of iris would have
helped a little bit she would have shot
anybody on a dime like Joe is
trigger-happy she's sort of like the
earth-2 version of Joe because they
flipped positions he's a lounge singer
who ended up dying during season two
she's a badass detective so just a
couple story problems a few things that
they should have explained a little bit
earlier and made a little bit clearer
but that's how she was able to kill
Savitt are and when you think about it
even if she hadn't have shot him I mean
he would have gotten to Barry but the
paradox wave would have washed over him
anyway so as of this moment right here
he was dead in the next couple of
seconds no matter what so she was really
just getting a shot in right before the
finish line well let me know what was
your takeaway from this and actually
revisiting some of those earlier
episodes maybe start thinking about the
reverse flash again so I will do a
season four reverse flash video about
how I think that he can return there's
all kinds of really cool stuff that's
going on Supergirl just confirmed that
rain is going to be the season three
bill and they cast Odette Annable which
i think is a badass she's from banshee
so if you guys want me to do a video
about that just let me know in the
comments but there's all kinds of comic
book stuff happening this week there'll
be new Wonder Woman posting tomorrow
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Carol Greene please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round in this video I'll
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video while you wait for that click
here for a brand new spider-man iron
spider and you can click here for my
non-spoilery Wonder Woman review thank
you so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight